apples magic keyboard for the iPad pro
is here but there are still a lot of
unanswered questions surrounding it like
why is there no top row of function keys
why the new floating iPad design why
does it waste so much why does it cost
three hundred to three hundred and fifty
dollars and why would anyone actually
pay that much for it so in this video
I'm gonna break down everything that I
know about how to best use the magic
keyboard as well as what I think about
the quality of the materials the keys
and the trackpad and finally I'm gonna
explain why I think this is Apple's
master plan for the iPad pro just from
the unboxing experience we can tell the
Apple is focusing on this product being
very simple to use and it shows because
all you have to do to set it up is place
your iPad pro close to the case and it
magnetically snaps into place and before
you can even bring your hands down to
the keyboard it's already connected and
same with the trackpad the cursor shows
up instantly it does this by using the
smart connector which gives a hardwired
connection between the keyboard and the
iPad which provides power for the keys
and trackpad to work reliably without
any lag at all not having to rely on a
Bluetooth connection and not requiring
batteries that need to be recharged and
that's just one of the things that sets
this magic keyboard apart from the other
options because this is the one and only
case with a trackpad that uses a smart
connector for the iPad pro what's great
is that it also supplies power for the
keyboard backlighting which the old
smart keyboard folio didn't have and it
gets even better since it actually turns
on automatically as it gets dark in your
room because it takes data from your
iPads ambient light sensor that's used
for the displays auto brightness and if
you want to turn it on manually there's
a backlighting brightness slider within
the hardware keyboard options in the
settings now one question that people
have is does the keyboard case with the
backlighting cause your battery to drain
quicker well says the lights are LEDs
they take very low power and the
keyboard and trackpad take barely any
power at all one feature that you
literally cannot get
on any other keyboard case for the iPad
is the USB C port that's built into the
hinge that can actually charge your iPad
pro through the smart connector which in
turn frees up the original port on the
iPad pro for things like hooking up a
storage device now let's talk about that
hinge the back of the case has two
portions at the bottom which snaps into
place as you open it on the top which
can be used to adjust angles and this
means that your iPad pro floats in the
air which has a couple of benefits first
of all Apple was the ipad to remain a
touch first device so the floating
design keeps the ipad conveniently
closer to you and the second benefit is
that at anytime you can simply lift the
iPad pro off of the case to use it as a
tablet and because the case uses a smart
connector the keyboard instantly
disconnects which doesn't happen with
Bluetooth keyboards which force you to
turn them off in order to use the
on-screen keyboard a lot of people
complain that you can't fold the case
back and use it in tablet mode but
that's the whole point of this floating
design so you don't have to deal with
the extra weight or trying to pry the
iPad from the case you simply lift it
off with one hand and then when you're
done with tablet mode just put it back
on the case and you're instantly back to
laptop mode and when you're finished
it's easier than ever to use one hand to
fold it down and take it with you and as
far as adjustability of the angles I
found it was perfectly fine
99% of the time for when you're using it
as a laptop now there's no doubt that
this keyboard case is heavy and Apple
did that on purpose
because if they didn't it would be
extremely top-heavy and this would cause
it to easily tip over but with the extra
weight you get a really solid and sturdy
solution and what's great about the
magnetic connection is that it's so
strong that there's no way that the iPad
pro will fall out unless you're
intentionally trying to budget as for
the materials they're using the same
polyurethane rubbery finish which I
personally don't really like since it
smudges very easily but if they chose a
different finish
it could have been even more heavy and
as for cleaning it Apple recommends
simply using a soft slightly damp
lint-free cloth don't use any chemicals
now let's move on to the keyboard
appala says it uses the same scissor
switch keys as their MacBook keyboards
and it's true these keys feel so much
better than the smart Keyboard folio
that the keys alone are worth it for
those who do a lot of typing and I'd say
that these keys are better than on any
other keyboard case like even the bridge
pro my favorite thing about the keyboard
is that it supports the same shortcuts
that you get on a MacBook and if you're
unsure about which shortcuts are
supported simply hold down the command
button within any app to see the full
list of shortcuts for that app and my
favorite shortcut is command + tab which
cycles through all of your apps letting
you press Q to close an app or let go of
command to enter into the selected app
now the main issue that people have is
the lack of a top row of function keys
so why did an Apple add this well I
myself only use the brightness and
volume controls on my work IMAX keyboard
and that would have been incredibly
useful on the magic keyboard but I know
that there are people who use other keys
like media controls for pausing and
skipping tracks I think the reason Apple
didn't add this is first of all they've
never added it on any of their keyboard
cases before and there honestly isn't
much room for it on the keyboard itself
since they already had to squeeze down
the trackpad size in order for even the
number keys to fit properly without
being hidden underneath the floating
iPad and asked for there not being an
escape key you can actually go into the
Settings app then general keyboard
hardware keyboard modifier keys and you
can actually switch the caps lock key to
function as an escape key but I'd say
that you don't really need that Escape
key
since the trackpad gesture support is so
good that it'll be quicker to use that
instead
for example while watching a YouTube
video just pinch with two fingers to
exit full-screen mode and you can also
swipe up with three fingers to get to
the home screen or swipe up and stop to
get to the app switcher as far as the
quality of
the trackpad I can tell you that you
will never find a better trackpad on any
other keyboard case out there it's
actually made out of a single pane of
glass which is the material Apple uses
for their excellent MacBook trackpads
with a plastic trackpad like on the
Logitech combo touch it isn't as smooth
of an experience especially if your
finger isn't completely dry and on that
trackpad it uses a diving board design
meaning that the top of the trackpad is
incredibly hard to click while the
bottom is very easy with the trackpad on
the magic keyboard case you get a really
unique design where the clicking
pressure is even no matter where you
click and the best part is that you can
go into the trackpad settings within the
general menu and enable tap to click
which makes using a trackpad a thousand
times better and my favorite option
within those settings is to finger
secondary clip which lets you instantly
right-click by tapping with two fingers
and then on top of that you can go into
the accessibility settings then point
your controls to customize basically
everything about how the trackpad works
like disabling the annoying trackpad and
nurses setting which leads to inaccuracy
and also disabling the pointer
animations so your cursor won't morph
into buttons anymore
so as far as the overall keyboard and
trackpad experience you literally can't
beat it on any other keyboard case and
that's one of the reasons why Apple
priced it's so high so let's answer that
question
why else would Apple price it at three
hundred to three hundred and fifty
dollars well the way I see it is that
Apple wants to start a trend just look
at the original earpods for example when
they were released they were
ridiculously expensive but despite all
of that they were wildly successful and
the entire earbud industry followed in
apple's footsteps they succeeded because
one they added incredible amounts of
functionality and reliability that made
them just work so well - the design was
totally unique and it acted as a symbol
for the Apple brand and
they were more expensive than expected
so it created a sense of exclusivity
that started all of those broke memes
which actually made the air pods sell
even better and if you think about it
the magic keyboard case adds so much
more functionality than any other
keyboard case and the smart connector
makes it the most reliable option as
well
the new floating design is original and
incredibly unique so if you see a
floating tablet you know it's an iPad
pro so it acts as a symbol of the Apple
brand and finally the price is expensive
so it gives consumers are really special
feeling to own this keyboard case just
like it did with the original air pots
and there you have it that's apple's
master plan for the iPad pro they want
this magic keyboard case to become
successful and act as a symbol for the
Apple brand to push the entire industry
forward and if you think about it
they've been planning for this keyboard
for years we know this because all the
2018 iPad pro the smart connector was
not only relocated but they made it
quite a bit larger than before and it
wasn't really being used for anything
until now that larger smart connector
was actually designed to support
pass-through charging which we finally
got with the magic keyboard case and
that larger connector is why the 2018
model also supports this case and not
only the new 20/20 iPad pro what this
ultimately shows us is that Apple has
been planning for this moment for years
and that's also why they've slowly
increased the price of the iPad pro so
that together with this magic keyboard
case it would cost around the same as
one of their entry-level Mac books so
whichever one you end up buying for your
computing needs Apple is still making
the same amount of revenue and that is
the final piece of Apple's master plan
for the iPad pro if you enjoy this video
tap the like button and click the circle
above so you don't miss out on our full
review of this keyboard case coming soon
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]